depuis ce matin l'histoire d'adama cissé
est l'un des sujets les plus commentés
sur les réseaux sociaux adama cissé 37
ans était il ya quelques temps encore
employé comme agent de propreté à paris
mais c'était avant qu'une photo de lui
endormi sur son lieu de travail ne
soient postés à son insu sur les réseaux
sociaux
suite à la découverte de cette
publication les employeurs d'adama ont
décidé de licencier l'agent pour faute
grave
si c'est ce matin que cette affaire a
éclaté effet massivement réagir les
internautes les faits remonte pourtant à
c'est à cette époque qu'un internaute
avait publié la photo damas six est en
train de dormir dans les rues de paris
un message de délation ouvertement
haineux dont le commentaire de l'auteur
ne laisse aucun doute sur l'intention de
la démarche
ce soir à 17 heures 40 rue jean lanthier
appareils voilà à quoi servent les
impôts locaux des parisiens à payer les
agents de propreté à roupiller on
comprend pourquoi paris et si
dégueulasse
un message qui fera son effet puisque il
conduira au licenciement de l'agent
d'entretien tout de suite une bataille
juridique s'engage si la société qui
employait l'homme ne cautionne pas ce
type de comportement de la part de ses
collaborateurs pour l'avocat d'adama si
c'est l'employeur tape très très fort
pour pas grand chose c'est cet après
midi que l'affairé passé au conseil des
prud'hommes
adama cissé était avec nous ce soir pour
évoquer cette affaire alors un employé
licencié à cause d'une photo sur twitter
choquer ou pas choquer
un employé donc viré à cause d'une photo
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est vrai que
ça fait des ravages
alors avant de laisser la parole à damas
six et merci d'être avec nous à damas ce
soir merci de nous avoir rejoints
vous avez 37 ans vous êtes père de
famille vous avez été licencié suite à
cette photo vous allez tout nous
raconter et le responsable d'adama
l'avait autorisé à prendre une pause
adam a enlevé ses chaussures parce qu'il
avait mal au pied gauche c'est ça il
raconte alors vous vous êtes choqués
gilles verdez bien sûr parce que il est
en pause c'est un métier où on embauche
très tôt un métier très fatigant c'est
des gens qui souffre qui bossent
énormément
il est en pause donc non seulement c'est
amoral mais c'est illégal parce que on a
le droit il ya même des entreprises qui
recommande d petite pause sieste chez
elle donc là il se repose pour reprendre
le travail
c'est contestable aux prud'hommes je
pense qu'il va gagner
il n'a pas être licencié pour ça
l'entreprise est en tort on vous propose
bien sûr la question également chez vous
alors vous à damas vous avez appris que
cette photo créé la polémique sur
internet
vous l'avez appris par l'un de vos
responsables c'était en fait c'était
plein de mon responsable c'était
l'inconnu que je connais pas un inconnu
d'accord voilà voilà
et la personne a pris la photo mais
après l'arrêt avant il a pris la photo
je suis même pas au courant c'est ça moi
j'avais mal au chili gauche il a déjà
l'air tout et tout il n'est pas venu
vers moi pour me demander et l envie de
prendre ma photo pour la co2 solution
est d'abord à mon travail puis moi je
trouve c'est pas normatif qui n'a pas
venu vers moi pour me demander pour me
donner la question plein de gens qui
prennent déjà sur les réseaux s'il a
appelé les pompiers
vous avez un problème vous choyer sida
ma pause on m'a rien fait et puis malgré
moi a lancé cela et vous a demandé de
voile à dos noir il vous a mis dans une
situation inextricable
alors jean michel maire vous êtes le
seul à battre choqué dit ne suis pas je
triste évidemment pour lui c'est
terrible de perdre son travail surtout
qu'on fait un travail déjà fatigue en
cela des horaires impossibles etc
mais moi je trouve qu un moment fait un
peu responsable de ses actes quand on
fait un show comme ça qu'ils riches peu
logique dans ce sens qu'on on s'affiche
un peu on a pas il faut prendre un peu
faire ça discrètement conçoit faty et
moi parfois je fatigue et travaille
énormément mais parfois quand je me
plante
j'adore allard et ça c'est pas le moment
on est d'accord mais de ça mais quand on
fait une sieste ouvertement comme ça
devant tout le monde et ça on sait qu'il
va re des conséquences je veux pas
croire dans votre tête à dix au bout de
cinq genres les pieds croisés comme ça
les chaussures devant que ça devienne
pas fait réagir quelques uns au texte a
forcé alors on pouvait on peut rester
habillé sa soirée dormi un peu comme ça
que ça
mais le juste comme ça pour moi n'était
pas que c'est la provoc mais c'est un
peu vous avez un peu cherché feu sans le
vouloir vous chaleur les emmerde tous
réagir aujourd'hui
du coup vous avez perdu votre travail
depuis à damas et c'est vrai que adama
ça faisait huit ont travaillé pour cette
entreprise il n'avait jamais eu aucun
problème avec vous et suite à la
diffusion de cette photo
donc il s'est fait virer voilà
aujourd'hui la décision est tombée
donc vous vous êtes choqués raymond là
c'est ça qui va pas moi je suis je suis
choqué c'est le manque de discernement
le monde et des états de service on dit
souvent les états de service c'est un
métier physique et ramassent les papiers
dans la rue ramasse voilà on le sait
après s'il n'a pas vu de conneries
avance il n'a pas fait qu'andré avant
ici peut le prouver qu'il a pas eu
d'avertissement ni deux ni de
recommander la il est ce que j'ai de la
peine pour lui parce que il faut il faut
que cette entreprise fasse machine
arrière mais je suis partagé quand même
pourquoi je suis partagé parce que moi
je fais un métier aussi physique tu
t'endors comme ça dans la rue peut-être
que tu avais mal au pied mais qu'est ce
que tu as fait la nuit aussi pour dormir
en pleine journée comme ça il ya ce
premier point est le deuxième point où
je veux pas aller dans le sens de
jean-mi parce qu'évidemment c'est un
drame mais moi je me mets à la place du
patron et de cette entreprise si moi
j'ai un salarié avec mon nom de mon
entreprise qui dort dans la rue par
terre je passe pourquoi je passe pour un
mec qui exploite ses employeurs a même à
les mettre au sol
donc il ya un moment donné l'entreprise
elle doit le réintégrer ou lui donner un
dédommagement si elle veut plus de lui
mais c'est pas logique de l'avoir
licenciée pour ça mais j'ai quand même
ce petit ce petit truc vert jean-mi de
me dire ils portent quand même les
affaires de l'associé de sa société sur
lui et c'est pas une belle image comme
ça de dormir dans là on va savoir où on
est à damas aujourd'hui il va tout le
dire valérie bénaïm sauf que sauf que
l'entreprise rêve
non pas parce qu'elle a été chagriné
mais parce que en fait ya une pression
dans le blick rôle de twitter exacte et
la cnl et noël réagir à chaud on aime le
minimum c'est de convoquer son employé
pour connaître exactement les raisons le
minimum c'est de dire à son employé tu
n'as jamais eu de problème donc
avertissement mais pas les licences et
c'est ce que je dis c'est vrai qui met
la photo on en parle
il vient d'en parler à damas oui celui
qui met la photo il doit pas donner ça
c'est un autre débat
essayez le gros problème aujourd'hui des
réseaux sociaux on en a parlé sans foi
là c'est un autre débat
on en reparlera mais là on est un peu
triste pour adama je conçois le sujet un
surf qu'il faut s'intéresser à lui
s'intéressait à lui à comment il est
aujourd'hui ce qui va faire plus tard je
me sens extrêmement triste extrêmement
touchée à damas déjà je voudrais vous
remercier d'être venus ce soir
merci où on aimerait savoir et on s'est
renseigné sur adama et je vous dis il
n'a jamais eu de problème dans cette
société jamais vous n'avez eu une
remontrance de vos patrons
non ça que j'avais irréprochable ça que
j'en arrive vraiment donc c'est ça qui
est un oui c'est ça que c'est sa
capitale l'un dessus excusez moi même si
j'ai un problème
soit on m'a fait partir dans une autre
société d'accord revenus travail notre
arrondissement et sur l'allongement je
connais pas très bien et par exemple le
périmètre d'un épais mais m motif
sûrement comme quoi je fais une
bilatérale
alors je connais pas l'arrondissement
avertissements pousse à la faute à faire
ça arrive à tout le monde a des
problèmes de retard pas de larmes des
transports rappelle jacques botti comme
quoi échanger viennent au travail
implique je n'ai pas n'avait jamais eu
de problème d'absence je vous avez
toujours été là oui je répète que je
suis triste pour lui
et à damas est ce que au moment où vous
êtes allongé comme ça pour française est
ce que ça nous a traversé l'esprit
commun que ça pouvait me porter
préjudice nous de faire la synthèse
comme ça dans la rue ou pas du tout
jamais fait ça excuse et les pensions
vous êtes allongé comme ça est ce que ça
vous ai dit tu te fais pas le faire ou
pas du tout j'ai jamais habité de faire
les 16 comme ça là que jamais la douleur
mon cv
vous aviez mal au point d'accord si jean
torchis c'est ça et quand j'ai dit sur
les marchés
et du moment un coup j'arrive pas à
tenir c'est saddam à trois mois est
maintenant dormir
est ce que tu voulais tant dormi ou
est-ce que tout non je te reposer car
soit ils voulaient passant dans le sujet
fait comme ça pourtant normes identiques
alors juste eux j'aimerais
officiellement parce que je trouve tout
à fait abjecte en fait c'est que cette
photo là soit recevable pour vous virer
tout ça parce que ben oui c'est de
l'incitation la délation et pourquoi y'a
pas pire en fait c'est vraiment celle
affichée dacor ac c'est la fin des
rapports humains entre eux comment tu
disais izard également whissell avait ça
c'est de conduire et benjamin bien sûr
non mais c'était pour nuit fait pour
nuire
oui mais bon reprenons est ce que vous
êtes shopi bah oui bien sûr ça que
j'écris parce qu'on fait du bon ça c'est
que pour faire pour produire à ce
monsieur est dans le symbole qu'elle
n'assure aucun intérêt au questionnaire
et on a vu les temps que l'entreprise
ait une raison en met plein on et 106
paon prom à la première ce monde comme
ça ça ne se fait pas c'est illégal
non mais c'est jacques rogge alors à
damas je vais vous aimiez beaucoup votre
travail
comment vous aimiez beaucoup votre
travail bien j'aime bien mon travail ça
fait ça fait combien de temps que vous
viendrez vider mon travail ça fait huit
ans fait huit ans je sais ce que vous
nous avez dit là vous êtes donc
licencier oui là je suis licencié sans
emploi oui sans emploi seulement je
cherche j'ai déposé mes cv partout de
l'ebre j'ai travaillé pendant un mois
d'octobre vous avez une famille vous
avez 2 vous êtes père de famille oui
vous avez combien d'enfants je bosse et
j'ai quatre enfants et jeunes en beauce
il tient les restos au pays
d'accord vous êtes de quelle origine au
mali d'accord juste aujourd'hui est-ce
que vous êtes triste de la situation
est ce que vous avez envie vous avez pu
discuter avec vos patrons leur expliquer
ou pas du tout je dispose ce qui m'a
choqué j'ai dit ce qu'il est patron m'a
convoqué après le travail oui c'est
après le travail montrer cette photo là
d'accord money samui j'ai dû me sers moi
bien sûr
ils m'ont dit qu'est ce que vous avez
vous élisez moi l'eau s'est vu alors
vous aimez savent que j'ai mal aux
civils
les u10 a qui savent lire 1 ben muna la
maladie au travail là bas avant que je
vois c'est le travail donc quand je
faisais marc ses pieds la montée des
samares de laisser vie et des collants
c'est user les services est pas facile à
guérir quand il fait froid ça tient
surtout dans le métier dans le même
temps mettez vous faites là on va voir
vous allez être jugée aux prud'hommes
vous avez fait appel aux prud'hommes je
crois que ces séquences et quand le
jugement c'est là c'est le résultat je
crois que ce sera en juin le 19 juin vie
d'accord donc ça vous a coûté énormément
de frais aussi d'avocats tout ça ou
comment ça s'est passé
non j'étais avec moi j'ai toujours donné
à mon avocat je suis agitée avec mon
avocat il est d'accord ok très bien
c'est un avocat commis d'office
et oui d'accord alors igor et grichka
que vous pensez de cette cette affaire
vous êtes sûrement en choquant c'est
extrêmement choquant pour pour deux
raisons la première c'est qu'en effet
n'importe qui peut exercer son contrôle
social comme ça pour une photo la
diffuser le commentaire qui accompagne
la photo est épouvantable après voilà où
passe nos impôts etc
heureusement le commentaire c'est assez
insupportable oui et puis la deuxième
raison c'est en effet de créer de la
détresse humaine comme ça on comprend
pourquoi paris et si les gueux la santé
allemand
là c'est vraiment comme tu le disais de
la délation mais sait on entre dans une
dans une époque est extrêmement
dangereuse à cause de ça jean michel2 le
cad à damas il est triste évidemment ce
qu'on a devant nous mais il est pas
unique il ya plein de gens qui se font
virer parce que les vidéos de
surveillance dans leur société dans la
magasin parce qu'ils ont dormi au
travail ou qu'ils ont fait à la barre
est une faute
ils sont virés la surveillance et les
vidéos maintenance on sait qu'il avait
un arrêt de maladie pour ça pour ça je
suis sûr qu'ils profitent pas le mec
profites pas de la sécu il vient
travailler même avec sa cheville éclaté
et se retrouve licencié à damas
prochaine fois je sais pas est-ce que
c'est qu'est ce que vous auriez à dire
aujourd'hui pour vous défendre et pour
dire voilà que vous vous avez envie de
travailler vous avez été irréprochable
pendant huit ans qu'est ce que vous
auriez à dire aujourd'hui à vos anciens
patrons bah moi je n'ai clairement non
je n'ai plus avec lui à mon ancien
patron chine est clair mon ancien patron
vous êtes déçu de sa décision en
commandes est restée déçue de sa
décision lui voit la façon imagée
saint-just voilà sa chaîne m'a viré
c'était super c'est pas normal c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui
comment vous faites pour vivre bon
aujourd'hui chômage
c'est ça donc d'accord et on vous avez
envie de retravailler notre société la
mairie doit rien peut pas faire casser
une boîte privée même de chercher
un autre emploi s'y trouvaient voilà un
problème j'ai pas travail on espère que
vous allez trouver très vite quelques
jours voilà s'il ya des gens qui nous
regardent des gens de la mairie de paris
ce qu'on peut faire quelque chose pour
adama je vous le dit et on a on a vu le
dossier il était irréprochable il ya
toujours fait son travail
malheureusement là c'est un concours de
circonstance parce que vous étiez vous
êtes endormi de fatigue mais cette
fausse dent risque de encore lui porter
préjudice à bath et survient sur deux
dans de nombreux ça va donner un peu ce
qu'a mis aux prud'hommes série là on
espère pour vous que ça va bien se
terminer à damas je voudrais vous
remercier
northug a d'abord été
ça va bien merci cas que ça va
s'arranger dans le pied me gossin